hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to huniepop now we just
got done with Jessie so we gotta go and
do other stuff that is creepy and
abnormal for normal people in actual
society but because we're in a game we
can be as previously watched is that um
anyway I want to go now
so now that I've I forget wait okay I
think it's just Tiffany and Nikki is
left I believe and this could be quite
difficult because the puzzles are
starting to be bad but a cow is
completed keyonna completed Adria Audrey
completed Lola completed Jessi complete
belly complete queue complete Momo
complete Celeste complete okay so
Tiffany and Nikki are next and that
means I could meet up with Nikki or I
can meet up with Tiffany tonight so bye
Jesse goodbye shut up bah bah okay bye
bye
okay now that I get over the trauma of
the last few episodes that I've been
recording because I recorded all the
previous episodes in one big bunch so I
got to like experience all of it in one
big clump and it was a bit much for me I
mean I'm uh I'm a man of great pride and
you know I'm very skittish when it comes
to actual ladies so I don't know Gabi
anyway so hey you want to go on and date
you want to date me maybe I've got video
games we can coin it hang out in my
house be my guess I don't have anything
better to do well if you put it like
that you know it makes me feel pretty
good about myself but I mean you could
just you know be a little nicer to me
because considering done we'll take you
on date buy you dinner and what uncaf
generally good time you could be a
little nice bigger how do you think
alone you know
okay lovely if you stay it's it's
literally the afternoon I mean I don't
know what more you could want for me it
is literally the afternoon okay oh I'm
so cool I'm done I'm done already I am
smoking look at this I'm so good at
dating oh oh don't you love me yet I
slept with everyone else huh what you
underestimated me sorry I was in my own
moment there I was really absorbed in
how great I am and how amazing that my
entire me is and it's pretty good and
pretty good I gotta run man
pretty girl oh yeah that was it the
desert slave the quote-unquote desert
slave for Celeste you know not copyright
in any way by any wars of the stars in
any capacity there and she's definitely
not a copyright of any World of Warcraft
drew an eye of some sort that just be
ridiculous but hey it's me the earthling
lover of lovely lovely lately it's me
markiplier how you doing
I don't have time to ask you on day time
because talking based on your knowledge
of lab lab lab lab and all the universe
my planet in your solar system well I
would say Pluto but it's been knocked
down from Planet status so I'm actually
gonna go say mercury that is right very
good
Pluto's a planet damn it Oh light like
comment favorite and subscribe if you
think Pluto's a planet it it sure is
okay wait no Tiffany's asleep that's
such [ __ ] this is [ __ ] alright I
gotta read you alright
oh hi goodbye I'll see you Celeste even
though you're a weird alien and I am
home anyway okay thank you
someone told me that I needed to do this
because my inventory was filling up I
need to give her or the underwear cuz
she that's what she wants apparently so
I just got to put my entire collection
into her face and she wants the tissue
gone I wanna hear good
you want to hear good things how about
this right you won't be having much need
for these anymore huh train me for what
I don't know what you gave me you even
have the honeybee anymore it's health
you would gift by life I thought this is
what people told me to give this to you
am I just gonna be collecting these
underwear why do I have their underwear
why would I steal their underwear that's
the weirdest thing doubles the current
passion level but that's not doesn't
help it oh I'm gonna get the passion
anyway it's a bunch of baloney hello I
go apparently your peoples favorites I
got a new message for me I couldn't fall
asleep last night for shi'ite I was
reading all these creepy bosses online
then I just keep hearing things like
noises and [ __ ]
okay who was taking the picture who took
the what ghost was looking over you and
took the picture who hangs a camera that
far above their butt what oh oh I see
she does porn oh sorry little
exclamation there sorry I have no
subtlety ever so I just explained these
things
that's bad hey hey how's it going there
my name's markiplier and welcome to
let's date oh that's I should use a
pickle
hoo hoo hoo who's watching wants me to
use that pickup line at some point in my
life hey am i fired welcome to let's
play you oh god that'd be horrible
now I commentate the entire date and I
come tater after the debut oh that was a
joke someone made till I lick oh that
was in my reading mean comments but here
someone said that I probably commentator
was having sex
oh my god that's so funny all I need to
do that again those really funny okay
anyway
um what was I doing what do you like I
don't even know what do you like no
that's not you talent okay so talent is
what you like I maxed out on everything
I need tel & tel & tel & town I have no
talent there's no telling nothing here
is talent okay that'll work
okay that'll work okay alright let's go
on another date I've strategized every
avenue about this there's nothing you
can do to surprise me on this date there
will be no yeah too many things
happening either we're not on the fourth
art level and it's not night that's the
only time that the sex could happen I'm
an expert on the sex and I know these
things
okay time to start making some
balls-to-the-wall loop knot I'm talking
about tennis balls don't get too excited
lady there's no sex happening no action
is being done this is a purely platonic
date until the next one then we'll get
our freaky deaky down till dawn but
until that absolutely no no key time to
finish this fish
Hey look at me I'm the greatest data but
nothing's happening do not expect
anything at the end of the stage don't
even give me a look
no kiss on the cheek no nothing I guess
I should have given you more credit yeah
whatever you should have but you're not
gonna give me more nothing I don't want
nothing until later oh that actually
hurt ow we out scribbles okay this other
girl better be available now better be
available all right I'm gonna do a swing
by on Celeste this is how humans do
Celeste they just touching base and go
it's got touch and go I'm not gonna
touch enough I don't want nothing to do
with you purely platonic hundred percent
propeller I didn't expect to see you
here at this time all right whatever
oh come on how am I supposed deep huh
this bunch [ __ ] mug balls and that's
needle mantas Bay you're next screw you
no not like that I don't want it
this is a load of baloney hey there you
are still out hey there shut up I don't
I'm not even here for you shut up shut
up shut up shut up shut up shut up shut
up shut up shut up shut up shut up
bing-bong bing-bong be shut up Bing well
I guess it's just wherever available at
night this time I'm not gonna be picky
but if it's Nikki my plans did not go
towards Nikki but I mean it does matter
she's cutie I guess that it's living in
the cab he did Hey Dude Gabbar dude
sounds cool sounds cool cuz hey bye how
this sounds cool c'mon let's go with our
current plan which is Tiffin ona
tiffany tiffany it's time you know what
time it is apparently or maybe you don't
but frankly I don't really mind what do
you like okay flirtation so I've got
some flirtation I've got some weird
chemicals that I'm gonna pull out of my
bag and then throw at you and then I'm
gonna mix some gems together and it's
gonna make you wild and hot it's gonna
be crazy but before you do that I really
need to plan this out because I need a
strategy of attack or else it's not
gonna work out but do we do of us I just
go say there right now actually I guess
I got a pretty good generic one hang on
I need to look at this idk I just felt
like sending this to you like I like you
and stuff is it sexy idk I hope you like
it
is it bad Matt Matt what is it what is
it Matt it's a lot Toby yeah it's an ass
oh oh that's not as bad as I thought it
was gonna be there's been other ones
that have been worse than that
good job Nikki I think well I don't know
if this is something to say good job
about but you guys can't see a damn
thing because it's so censored that sure
is
hey let's go on a date you and I let's
do the date thing but before I do that
I'm gonna make it a little easier on
myself cuz I'm weird and creepy like
that it's part of the game
Rose are you no not at all okay let's go
on a date I'm ready to go it's part of a
game it's part of the game don't judge
me
don't don't don't judge me no one judge
me are you sure this is it too expensive
I'm fine with that
hey come on I'm rolling in money I ain't
actually a college student I lied to you
also I banged your mom okay yes okay the
festivities are over or have they just
begun okay I'm gonna try to do this one
the least creepy as possible like watch
a movie at your apartment or something
are you talking down Flicka chill oh yes
God does enough time for that
oh hey I can't believe this oh sorry
hi hi I tried to say least creepy as
possible Matt put on a science lecture
and then put a guinea of the Sun
exploding not-not-not symbolic in any
way but also put in a meteor smashing
into earth that'll be good and then
light weights um uh like dogs and
animals wrestling in a field that'll be
totally platonic and not get a move
so replace your poisonous pom bill nine
cent every time she says something it's
bill bill okay got it
okay that's not so bad
it's Ollie it's always a crapshoot of
whether it's gonna be like horribly
horribly bad or whatnot but okay
all right then moving on
that was a good science lecture
everybody we sure did good today I'm so
happy that we came together not like
that don't get your mind out of the
gutter I'm so glad that we were here
together today to enjoy life and all the
life history wait okay so thank you
everybody so much for watching click the
annotation for more totally platonic
non-sexual eyes anything in the
description below there's tons of games
where none of nothing happens it's
family fun for the whole family thanks
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
okay well thank you